hey everyone this is stephanie wong
cloud developer advocate and today i am
really really excited because we have
our google fellow here eric brewer he
has been here helping to build google
and google cloud's infrastructure over
the last like decade and we are so
honored to have him here today so eric
thank you so much for being here how are
you today i am fantastic hanging out in
wonderful marin county enjoying being
remote for today same here i am just a
stone's throw away from you but i do
want to jump into it right away i was
actually able to dig up this tweet that
you had a while ago i think it was about
10 years ago and you were talking about
your initial plan to help build
infrastructure here at google and how
much work there was left to do so what
was that initial plan and how did it pan
out well that was based on my thinking
really from the 90s so before vms were a
big deal i was working on what you would
now call cloud computing at uc berkeley
and was really based on a model that
used a lot of processes and services and
apis
and i still like that model better so
when i got to google i kind of felt like
we needed a new cloud that's a higher
level of abstraction
and of course that led to kubernetes and
all the things we do in the modern kind
of version of that
what's it like to see that come to
fruition and have the industry adopted
over time it's incredibly exciting even
when
you plan something like oh we should do
a
new orchestration layer based on
containers because it's more like how we
think the cloud should work it's more
like how google works internally
it's fine to say that but then you have
to like create the projects you have
decide to open source them you have to
get fellow travelers as i say other
groups that want to bet on this journey
and of course you need to get adoption
and all that happened and after maybe
eight years working on kubernetes it's a
remarkable place
and it's taken quite some time for us to
get to where we are today
i'm curious what was it like to be one
of the first and biggest supporters of
kubernetes
working on it from a very early stage
were there any unexpected challenges
that you underwent in implementing it
across google and also across the
industry well i think there were two
obvious hurdles internally the first was
we already had app engine and vms why do
we need a third way to do computing and
so there's some natural resistance to
change
and the answer is because the third way
is better than either one alone
and the second one is this is such a big
deal why would we open source it and we
didn't tend to do much open sourcing of
kind of
systems things as we do now that's kind
of a bit of changing philosophy
but for kubernetes i just felt it was
too big a change for industry for us to
do it by ourselves and open source was
an important part of giving the fellow
travelers that we needed yes yes and
it's had quite an impact as we know
today but you know tell me a little bit
more about the open source ecosystem
what it's grown to be and what it's
looking like over the next 10 years is
the cloud going to continue to change
are we moving towards more higher level
of abstractions or opinionated services
well yes yes and yes
so kubernetes is about this i think the
second largest open source project now
behind linux which makes a lot of sense
uh and is an achievement in itself but
really it's because it's now the cloud
platform or the enterprise platform and
the reason for that is it's both
versatile you can do many things with it
but also that it's easier to operate
than just the raw vms or raw disks and
so it's a good platform to build on but
again i think it's better viewed as a
platform for platforms
if you say well i really like clown run
it's easier to use the kubernetes that
is absolutely true but cloud run is not
you know general purposes kubernetes and
so the way i think about that is i want
many opinionated things
right that are vertically oriented on
top of kubernetes kubernetes is great
for building those things both inside
the enterprise and out and in the end
the collection will be kubernetes
becomes less visible because you're
using the things on top of it and your
daily experience with your your future
cloud
yes and and what i love about the cloud
space is that it's all about providing
both developer freedom and flexibility
but also empowering them to have that
optionality for these opinionated
services they want cloud providers to
give them the best of breed security for
example yes it's actually good that
there are many functions as a service
built on top of kubernetes and some will
be great some will be less great but the
fact that there's many of them is
actually a good thing for everybody
right
now okay you've done 10 years of this
type of work it's changed at a speed
that i'm sure nobody had expected
but what are you hoping to achieve over
the next 10 years anything that you
might predict will be the next wave or
fundamental shift or is it really hard
to say based on your experience so far
well i think one big one that we're in
the middle of is how to combine the
velocity you can get from something like
kubernetes and ci cd
security we clearly need as a nation and
in general for all nations
and so
a classic view of security is to say oh
i don't want to change anything
you know there might be vulnerabilities
but
it turns out it's the exact opposite if
you really want to be secure you have to
be able to update your software quickly
because there are latent security
problems that will be discovered and
then you'll need to fix them quickly and
so
my biggest focus at the moment is really
around open source security the supply
chains and its security and how to
really make that a much more opinionated
stretch from source code to actual
deployment having better metadata better
control of all those steps better
attestations which can make
proof statements about those
deliverables and so you'll understand
what your real risks are and of course
minimize as many attack points as
possible that is going to be a big
change also well that is a perfect tee
up because in our next video that we're
doing together we are going to be
talking more about how you have been
helping to build a better security
process for software supply chains and
how trusted software providers are the
future so thank you so much eric
everyone else stay tuned we are going to
keep these conversations coming at you
[Music]